Robert, can I ask you if you may to
quote some hadiths or verses from the
Quran that you find particularly
reprehensible?
>> Well, the Quran in chapter 98:6, it says
that the unbelievers from among the
people of the book, that is Jews and
Christians who don't accept Islam, are
the most vile of created beings. It says
that the uh the polytheists are unclean
in chapter 9:28. It says in chapter 9 29
to fight against even the people of the
book that is primarily Jews and
Christians until they pay the Jiza which
is attacks with willing submission and
feel themselves subdued which has been
the basis for the uh the
institutionalized secondass status for
non-Muslims under Islamic law. You have
Muhammad in a hadith saying that you
offer the he says I've been commanded to
fight against people until they confess
that there's no god but Allah and I his
messenger and when they do their lives
and their property will be safe. In
other words, their lives and property
are not safe. If they don't accept that
he is the messenger of Allah and there
are many many other let's bring in uh
Imam Ununus Dadwala who's an imam in
East London. Uh Imam Dadwala good
morning to you.
>> Good morning. Good morning. Um you've
heard Robert Spencer quote extensively
from the Quran and the Hadith. Um how
would you counter the words that he has
just put out there?
>> I think um before we even go there, I
think we we just need to understand
whether somebody like um Robert Spencer
or Pamela Gella should be banned in come
uh coming to this country or whether
their presence will be helpful or not.
And I think that's the debate that we
should be having. Um there should be
fairness in the application of any
banning orders. If we ban one extremist
on the basis of hate speech um on the
basis of community cohesion not being
conducive to the good of the uh of the
country or to the good of the public
then you know it's a the home secretary
needs to decide whether uh they should
allow Pamela Gella and Robert Spencer to
come to this country and especially on
on armed forces day. I mean is it going
to be uh helpful for these individuals?
Is it going to be respectful for these
individuals? Or is it going to be
distasteful uh for these individuals to
come and honor the memory of Dali Rigby?
>> But but what is what is what is what is
the the issue here as well? Immadala
it's the generalization. Um
>> well it's the well it's the it's the
ability of people such as Tommy
Robinson, such as Robert Spencer to be
able to quote from the Quran. But there
are many verses in the Bible. There are
many verses,
different textbooks which can be easily
taken out of context. And I think
here
>> I imm
sorry, but so often on this show we are
asked by our Muslim listeners. Why
haven't you got an imam on to counter
theologically counter some of the things
that put out there? Now you can't
unfortunately come on to this show and
evade that. you we have to we have to
take this stra because the failure to be
able to do that to counter that is part
of the problem which allows the EDL to
jump in and make up its own mind about
Muslims. So as an imam talking to Robert
Spencer and Robert Spencer has had
plenty discussions with imams over the
years haven't you Robert? Um, oh yes,
many, many. So, can we have this
discussion? Can he's put the quotes out
there, he said them. Now, as an imam,
someone who has studied the Quran back
to front, inside out, please explain to
us this context.
>> Well, the context is in this country
there are 3 million Muslims in the UK.
Are they they are following the Quran? I
am following the Quran. Am I ordered by
the Quran from the verses that he has
quoted which were from the time of 1400
years ago during uh uh a time of jihad,
a time of uh fighting non-Muslims at the
time? Are we ordered cuz I follow the
Quran fully. Am I ordered to kill so and
so and so and so who's walking down the
street whether they are a Jew or a
Muslim? No, I am not. And nor does any
Muslim have a right to kill anyone on
the streets of Britain, on the streets
of United States.
>> But are Jews and Christians inferior to
Muslims?
>> No, they are not. Every person is
valued.
>> So So it doesn't it doesn't say that in
the Quran. Then
>> if it says that it will be in a context.
So for example, if it says they are
unclean, it means they're spiritually
unclean.
>> So how do we then? Okay. So if they're
spiritually unclean then then that's
assumed does it not that they are not
the equal of Muslims.
>> No it's not about being equal. Every
person has to be respected and that's
why we can't take a life. You've heard
the verse being quoted.
>> Where's the quote? Where's the quote in
the Quran that says we are all equal
that Jews and Christians and Muslims are
equal.
>> Whoever takes a life any life whether
it's Muslim or non-Muslim it is like
taking the life of every single human
being. quite but there isn't anything in
the Quran that you can identify which
actually says
>> my head and I wasn't I wasn't asked to
be prepared for for
>> you are an imam I
>> I understand that but Robert Spencer has
been uh but
>> he's not an imam
>> yeah but he's been this is his field and
he
>> but Islam is your field surely
>> Islam is my field but I have not been
called to discuss whether Robert Spencer
and the verses of the Quran which he is
quoting I have been called to ask
whether he should be allowed in to this
country or
Right. But as I pointed out, the reason
that I wanted an Imam on the show
>> was to be able to counter the kind of
accusations that we hear from people
like Tommy Robinson and people like
Robert Spencer about it. Because the
problem is is that what what what the
problem is surely I imam Dadwella is
that
Muslims a very small minority of Muslims
these jihadists that Robert Spencer
speak of they are not contextualizing
these lines are they? So they are
feeling as though they've got cart
blanch.
>> Yeah. And the 99% who are are they not
following the Quran?
>> Well, the one but the 1% might argue
that they're not.
>> No, but that's the 1%. There's always
extremists in every single uh community.
Absolutely.
>> You can't you cannot generalize the
whole community based on the extremist
views. M
>> so if 99% who are following the Quran,
who are following Islam are not uh
taking that verse as literal, then why
is it that we should follow the 1%. Um,
Robert, please please explain further
how you coming to this country where
views such as yours already exist and
are articulated is doing anything to
help bond us together and to learn to
live with each other and to I mean I I
>> well it's doing exactly that. uh we're
we're showing that there's an
international coalition for freedom and
>> okay but are you are you also
>> determined to defend human rights and
equality of rights of all people before
the law
>> and within your speech is there any
mention of the fact that the vast
majority of Muslims are peaceful and we
are not against Muslims we are not
against Islam we are against extremism
is is there anything in your speech to
to say to
>> it's obvious from everything that we say
and do it's obvious to anyone who is
fair-minded It's obvious to anyone who's
interested in truth and actually reads
what we really say and listens to uh
what we really
put out at these rallies. The fact is
that like I said before, any Muslim who
genuinely stands for human rights and
rejects the idea of the death of the the
death penalty for the apostate and the
the uh the oppression of women, wife
beating that is sanctioned in the Quran
in chapter 4:34 and so many other
things. Any Muslim who rejects those
things and stands for the otherwise
universally accepted notions of human
rights such as were delineated in the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights of
the United Nations of 1948. Uh very much
invited to stand with us.
>> Okay. Imam Duda, do you want to come
back at the accusation that wife beating
is sanctioned in the Quran?
>> Wife beating is not sanctioned in the
Quran and that's why I've spoken against
wife beating. I always speak against
wife beating. And I think what we've got
to understand is you know Pamela Geller
Pamela Gella she's uh standing up for
Israel and you know she her language is
vile against Muslims. It's generalized
against Muslims and that's why on a
recent visit to Canada she was banned by
a synagogue. A Jewish woman a so-called
defender of Israel is banned from
speaking at a synagogue. The Toronto
Board of Rabbis denounces Pamela Gella
uh because of her visit to Canada. Why
was she invited? And this is the board
of deputies of rabbis in Canada. So I
mean for Muslims to to speak about uh
whether Pamela Gella or just question
whether Pamela Gella is conducive to the
public good in this country I think is
uh you know is quite natural.
>> But not Robert Spencer.
>> Robert Spencer as well. I mean you know
anyone who is trying to fuel hatred. We
we live in a society a peaceful society.
There are individuals who carry out act
of criminality. There are individuals
who are extremists. But you can't
generalize because of those criminals or
those extremists and start demonizing a
whole community. And those people who
are I mean look who's calling these
individuals. I think that that answers a
lot of questions. It's hateful people
who are calling hateful individuals uh
to a rally.
Robert,
>> uh, chapter 4:34 of the Quran says,
"Good women are obedient. As for those
that are not, give them a warning, send
them to separate beds, and beat them."
It's in there. Look it up. As far as
Pamela Geller getting banned in Canada
goes, this is part of an international
effort by leftists and Islamic
supremacists to silence any voices that
are standing up against jihad and
Islamic supremacism. And actually she
was banned by the first synagogue there
because a Muslim policeman threatened
the uh rabbi and told him that he would
lose his job as a chaplain for the area
if he let her speak. And so you see all
these things always go together. What we
have is a an unwillingness to debate, an
unwillingness to deal with the truth, an
unwillingness to grapple with the hard
issues that jihad raises and to come up
with genuinely helpful solutions. Why
aren't you do why aren't you doing an
interfaith conference of Islam? Why
aren't you rise to this?
>> Why aren't you saying I don't want to
speak to the EDL because the EDL in this
country have a terrible reputation that
there are balaclava wielding thugs who
have been involved in violence with the
police. You don't want to get involved
in giving a speech to them. You want to
get involved in giving a speech to an
interfaith conference where you can
discuss such issues. Surely that would
be about social harmony in this country.
We don't need anyone else coming over
here and creating
>> inviting me. interfaith conference is
inviting me because they listen to
>> why don't have you done your research on
EDL organization
>> have you done your research on the EDL
>> yeah have you the fact
>> well I interviewed the leader for an
hour and a half last week so yes
probably more so than you have
>> so I mean he was sitting right in front
of me for 90 minutes yesterday
>> the the the EDL does not advocate
violence and does not uh engage in
anything against it but it has group it
has some very unsavory characters who
claim to be members of it and in the way
that you condemn uh Islamic extremism,
surely you should be condemning
extremism within the EDL and having
nothing to do with it.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And so I'm very
>> So why are you speaking to them?
>> To know why do you keep interrupting me?
You asked me a question.
>> So why are you speaking to them? the the
I happen to know and have verified this
with Tommy Robinson and Kevin Carroll
that uh these people that come in and
give the Nazi salutes and have swastikas
and all that, they are uh often times
infiltrators who are trying to discredit
the organization. They go in to get
their picture taken somewhere. They're
immediately expelled. There is no
tolerance for that kind of behavior
within the EDL. And so that what we have
is a a situation where these people are
trumpeted by the media because you want
to portray the EDL in a certain way.
It's the same.
>> We're creating this, are we?
>> I know that uh that that I'm working for
freedom and human rights and who
constantly uh uh confronted by people
like this Nick Lols from Hope Not Hate
who plainly just fabricates this ad that
we supposedly ran and then tries to make
a case about it. And in his petition
saying that we should be banned from the
UK, he says we called all Muslims
savages, which we never have.